well this tells you everything in march
of last year the leadership of the
united states and of china
both declared national emergencies in
the u.s tony fauci warned congress that
reopening american businesses could
cause quote coronavirus outbreaks the
government may not be able to control
going outside tony fauci said was just
too risky
meanwhile in china where the coronavirus
originated a top
advisor to the chinese government
declared that the country was
experiencing a very different kind of
threat a more profound threat
the problem he said was a national
masculinity crisis
chinese boys quote have been spoiled by
housewives and female teachers
and they were becoming as a result quote
delicate timid and effeminate
in essence they were becoming people who
might listen to someone like tony fauci
left unchecked said the chinese
government advisor
the feminization of chinese boys would
quote inevitably endanger the survival
and development of the chinese nation
in january chinese government acted on
this recommendation
the education ministry of china released
a notice entitled proposal to prevent
the feminization of male adolescents
the goal was to quote cultivate students
masculinity
have you seen this on other channels by
the way kind of interesting isn't it
china won't explain the reasoning behind
this plan but
there are some clues last year we
learned that china has quickly developed
the world's largest naval force
in 2015 china had 255 battle force ships
now they have more than 360
and many of those ships are more capable
than anything in the american naval
fleet
so how are we responding to this well at
the white house yesterday joe biden
addressed it effectively what's the
american military's response
here's what joe biden said some of it's
relatively
straightforward work where we're making
good progress
designing body armor that fits women
properly
tailoring combat uniforms for women
creating maternity flight suits and
updating
updating requirements for their
hairstyles
and some of it is going to take and
uh you know it's an intensity
of purpose and mission to really change
the culture and habits
that cause women to leave the military
so we've got new hairstyles and
maternity flight suits pregnant women
are going to fight our wars
it's a mockery of the us military while
china's military becomes more masculine
as it's assembled the world's
largest navy our military needs to
become as joe biden says more feminine
whatever
feminine means anymore since men and
women no longer exist
the bottom line is it's out of control
and the pentagon's going along with this
again this is a
mockery of the us military and its core
mission which is winning wars
one of the few people who's been paying
attention to this is someone who served
in the us military indiana congressman
jim banks
recently he wrote a letter to the u.s
chief of naval operations asking why the
navy had included a book
racist filth by ibrahim x kendi on its
2021 reading list because that book
teaches exactly what the chinese
propaganda ministry teaches that america
is fundamentally immoral
congressman jim banks joins us tonight
congressman thanks so much
for coming on how could a book like this
really
filth wind up on a naval reading list
tucker i have no idea i mean we're in
the middle of a
60-day stand down something that the
entire military
is doing to rule out what they're
calling extremism
in the ranks right right now we're in
the middle of that
so you'll have to forgive me for being
astonished that the top
admiral in the united states navy would
put a book on his
recommended reading list to every sailor
in the united states navy
that says that america is racist that
capitalism is racist written by an
author that said that amy coney barrett
is a white colonizer because she adopted
a couple of african-american
children i mean this is astonishing to
me because at a time when we're supposed
to be rooting out extremism in the ranks
that's exactly what the united states
navy is pushing
uh for the for the sailors to read
that's why i wrote a letter to admiral
gilday i haven't heard back from him yet
i wrote it to him a couple of weeks ago
to bring his attention
to just how terrible of a concept this
book is that divides us
that weakens our military and that
ultimately distracts us
at a time when we need to be focused on
the on the threat that we face
in the great power competition with
china as you said who has a bigger navy
than we do so it's it's deeply troubling
to me but i don't have a good answer for
you why this book would be included on a
reading list
that usually includes interesting books
about the geopolitical issues that
america faces
and instead there's a book on the
reading list that tells all of our
sailors some who are very young just out
of high school that they're racist
and that america is racist so if you
wanted to destroy the us military you
would tell people serving in it that the
country
is not worth fighting for is there any
way to get
this admiral and other flag officers
up onto capitol hill and ask them why
you're betraying your country and trying
to destroy our armed forces
yes tucker the the admiral the top
admiral in the united states navy will
come and testify before the armed
services committee it will be the first
question
that i ask him when he does i've met him
before i've had lunch with him i
i i can't for the life of me understand
why he would defend
uh having this book on his reading list
let me tell you i served in the united
states navy
it was the most diverse experience of my
life and i have never met anyone who
raised their right hand and took the
oath of office put on the uniform who
didn't love america and believed that
america
was great so why we would push a book
and tell them to read a book that tells
them that america is rotten to the core
and that america is racist and the
institutions in our country including
the united states navy
is racist is beyond belief to me yeah
and should have to answer for it and pay
for it i would say congressman banks i
appreciate your bravery thank you
thank you